Did you know that one in four of
installed apps are never used.
In fact, only 26% of
apps are used daily,
which means that the majority
of apps just sit there.
If your app is one
of the unlucky ones,
I've got good news for you.
You can improve user
engagement by reminding users
to come back to your app
with Google Cloud Messaging
notifications.
In my experience, the
best way to learn GCM
is by running the sample code.
So in this video,
I will show you
how you can use an open
source project called
the GCM Playground to
get started quickly.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi.
I'm Jarek Wilkiewicz.
In this series,
I'm covering things
every developer
needs to understand
to be successful-- user
acquisition, engagement,
and earning money.
In this episode, we'll
focus on user engagement.
As you saw in the previous
video in this series,
driving installs
is what developers
need to focus on first.
But you can do much
more than that.
You see, users abandon
apps quite rapidly.
When asked, 34% of them
report they stop using apps
because they lost interest.
So how can you entice your
users to get back into your app?
User research shows that
notifications work very well.
Sending a notification
to the user
with a discount or a
coupon, a deep link
to bonus content, a
friend or family update,
or a cool new
feature announcement,
are all great ways to
get continued engagement
for your app.
According to Localytics,
app users with notifications
enabled used the app more often
than users with notifications
disabled.
This begs two questions--
how often can you
pop a notification?
And how do you
implement notifications?
First of all, pick
the right frequency.
Make sure your notifications
are relevant and targeted.
Marketers from leading
brands send notifications
somewhere between one
notification per month
to one per week.
Secondly, use a reliable
cloud infrastructure
so your messages don't
get lost in transit.
So how do you implement
notifications?
There are three parts to it.
First, you need
the business logic
to decide what to send,
to which users and when.
Typically, this runs in a
separate backend application
server and is specific
to your application.
Second, you need
the transport layer
to efficiently push messages
to millions of devices.
Third, your app should
handle processing
of incoming notifications.
The first part is something you
will need to build yourself.
But later in the video I will
show you how to get started.
Google Cloud Messaging takes
care of the middle part.
You know, the one
that efficiently
pushes messages to
millions of devices?
For the third part, GCM can
display notifications for you
automatically, or you can
implement your own display
logic.
Let's now talk about
message delivery.
When you want to send app
notification to your users,
with GCM, you don't have to
worry about managing client app
connections to your app server.
The message is sent
from your app server
and received by GCM
connection servers,
and reliably
delivered to your app.
GCM supports server to device
messaging, subscription
based topic messaging, and
even upstream messaging
from the client back
to the app server.
App stream messages can
be used for, for example,
automatically
dismissing notifications
on other devices belonging
to the same user.
GCM supports notifications
for Android, iOS,
and even Chrome clients.
When a message from GCM
Connection server arrives,
your app can display it
as an in-app notification,
or, if the app is not
in the foreground,
the notifications is displayed
in the notification tray.
In my experience, the
best way to understand GCM
is to take a look
at the sample code.
We have provided
it and two examples
in the GCM Playground
open source project, which
you can clone from GitHub.
The GCM Playground
comes with a web
UI you can use to send
notifications from a sample
Go backend app server to
Android, iOS, and Chrome
clients.
The GCM Playground
uses Docker containers
to package the examples
with their dependencies.
So it is easy to get started.
Here is an example sequence.
Once you've built and launched
the example Docker containers,
go to the web UI to
send notification.
The notification is delivered
to the sample application server
and distributed to the
registered Android, iOS,
and Chrome clients through
GCM connection servers.
In a real life
application, the server
is the component you would
integrate with your application
specific targeting logic.
The GCM Playground
makes it easier
by providing most of
the application server
GCM integration code as a part
of the GCM Go library, which
you can use in your
own app server.
Thank you for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]